you know I wonder where Superman changes
nowadays there haven't been proper phone
booths on random street corners for
years and it's not like he's gonna fit
in a cell phone are there just some
carefully removed scenes to meet
Superman movie now where he's just
letting little kal-el
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where we strive to be the Internet's
most ethical fictional conspiracy theory
show so there's a lot of spider-man
stuff happening right now there's the
new spider-man ps4 game enter the spider
verse later this year and as such I've
been rewatching the old Sam Raimi
spider-man movies to search for theory
fodder and you know what caught my
attention looking through all that Jay
jonah jameson one of the single best
characters in all of comic fiction not
only is he hilarious in those movies
Spiderman wasn't attacking the city he
was trying to save it that's slander it
is not I resent that slander is spoken
in print it's libel what really struck
me this time was his commitment to his
journalistic integrity Green Goblin
flies through the window and practically
sets all of JJ's offices on fire
clutching him by the throat and
demanding that he tell him who takes
Pisces pictures for the bugle Peter
Parker is literally right there outside
his office the two of them just haven't
gotten into a fight and what does Jay
Jonah do I don't know comes in the
matter line he lies to green Goblin's
face for as harsh as he can be he
protects the anonymity of his sources
and his employees with his own life it's
truly the mark of a heroic journalist
all of this got me thinking about other
superhero reporters specifically the
most famous one of them all Superman
when Superman puts on those magic
glasses he becomes mild-mannered Clark
Kent Star reporter for The Daily Planet
well maybe Star reporter is over selling
his rule a bit I logged into your
Dropbox to find copy just copy all right
nothing about football nothing about
friends of the metropolis library
throughout Batman V Superman dawn of
Justice we start seeing the inner
workings of the Daily Planet and well
the way they treat the news is a bit
concerning when the planet was founded
its stood for something very keen so
could you if it was 1938 but it's not
1938 but he cares about Clark Kent
taking on the Batman well he didn't care
about it until they saw this movie ah
self-awareness for the win but seriously
with behavior like that would the Daily
Planet be considered a good ethical
newspaper or is it just a whole lot more
fake news I mean Perry White is no Jay
jonah Jameson and usually that scene in
a good way but is it really so today I'm
taking a deep dive into the icy pool of
superhero journalism in an effort to
determine whether Superman the icon of
truth justice and the American Way is
working for a company that's just as
sleazy as the criminals he's working to
put behind bars now obviously I can't go
accusing one of the most iconic
fictional papers of being unethical
without setting up a few rules first so
I turned to the experts the Society of
Professional Journalists in their
mission to protect and improve
journalism has created some very clear
guidelines for journalistic ethics the
rules fall into one of four main
categories seek the truth and reported
minimize harm act independently and be
accountable and transparent now the
first one almost seems obvious has a
newspaper the planet should be
interested in seeking out the truth and
reporting it you know delivering the
news in an objective fashion but when
you actually look at how it operates
they really fail in some spectacular
ways as part of this category the
Society of Professional Journalists
lists one being vigilant and courageous
about holding those with power
accountable giving a voice to the
voiceless to boldly telling the story of
the diversity and magnitude of the human
experience seek sources whose voices we
seldom hear and three avoiding
stereotypes journalists should be
examining the ways their values and
experiences may shape their reporting
all of which are great goals
representing everyone fairly and equally
giving a spotlight to the stories that
have no other outlets let's see how
Perry White and the Daily Planet feel
about all that in the 1970
Superman the iconic and widely
considered best film version of Superman
Lois Lane comes in with a pitch for her
story violence it's got the ethnic angle
ah the ethnic angle okay let's give Lois
the benefit of the doubt and assume that
she's trying to I don't know give voice
to the voiceless so how does her
editor-in-chief Perry White respond Oh a
lady wrestler with a foreign accent
looks like Perry missed the day where
they taught point number three about
avoiding stereotypes
it truly does sound like Perry is
sacrificing his ethical integrity
because the story is merely about
minorities any way you slice it it is
clearly not a response that gives us any
sort of confidence that he's examining
ways that his values and experiences may
be shaping the reporting but that was
way back in the 1970s surely the modern
Perry White has been sufficiently woke
right
why aren't recovering this poor people
don't buy papers people don't buy papers
period Ken Perry and when you assign a
story you're making a choice about who
matters
good morning Smallville the American
conscience died the problems don't just
exist in the stories that Perry is
selecting but also how he's encouraging
those stories to be framed
another tenant of the Society is to
quote provide context take special care
not to misrepresent or oversimplify in
promoting previewing or summarizing a
story and what's the thing that we hear
repeatedly throughout the original
Superman film Perry White's official
motto that he teaches all his reporters
and good reporter doesn't get great
story Jimmy regardless of whether you're
stuck with a slogan slinging 70s
stereotyping Perry White or the modern
DCE use random story assigning Perry
White
working at the planet has always seemed
to be an ethical minefield now you're
probably thinking that Perry in both of
these cases is just trying to do what's
best for the Daily Planet making money
and selling more copies but that is
exactly why this code of ethics exists
in the first place to show reporters
where the line exists between a good
story and being a good journalist
point number two minimize harm so this
sounds like it should be a really simple
task for a newspaper that unwittingly
employs a superhero but this principle
is actually based
the need to balance the public's need
for information against the potential
harm or discomfort that information
getting out could cause them it
basically boils down to whether the
public knowing a certain piece of
information is going to be better or
worse for them and also whether
revealing that information is harmful to
the private citizen it belongs to
throughout Batman V Superman we witness
Perry White
repeatedly shutting down Clark's
attempts at an expose on Batman a man
who is for all intents and purposes and
out-of-control vigilante know about you
but it certainly seems like a piece of
information that would be pertinent to
the safety of the public but no
apparently according to Perry it needs
to stay under wraps nothing about
football
just the got-damn got them back thing I
told you not to pursue the police won't
help the press has to do the right thing
you don't get to decide what the right
thing
but it's even worse than Man of Steel
when Lois decides to bury her story on
the existence and identity of Superman
you know the first ever confirmed actual
super-powered alien to ever land on
earth ever I believe you saw something
Lois so whatever your reasons are for
dropping it that you're doing the right
thing can you imagine how people on this
planet would react if they knew there
was someone like this out there sure it
seems like Perry for once is taking his
responsibilities to his readers
seriously but I would argue that he's
making the wrong decision here as we see
later in the movie the public would soon
find out about Superman's existence
through his very public battle against
Zod a battle that causes panic fear and
extreme loss of life an introduction to
Superman as a peaceful entity through
Lois Lane's Daily Planet article prior
to that battle would have gone a long
way to mitigate the questions the public
would have had in the aftermath of that
battle circumventing not only a large
part of the general outcry and overall
atmosphere of fear present in Batman V
Superman but also what would just
circumvent a lot of that movie in
general which is not a bad thing but
really those two categories are nothing
compared to the mass of ethical
violations in the act independently and
be accountable entrance
in sections when it comes to acting
independently of the five rules listed
on the Society's website The Daily
Planet breaks the following for one
avoiding conflicts of interest real or
perceived disclosing unavoidable
conflicts two refusing gifts favours
fees free travel and special treatment
and avoiding political and other outside
activities that may compromise integrity
or impartiality or may just damage
credibility 3 being wary of sources
offering information for favors or money
not paying for access to news
identifying content provided by outside
sources whether paid or not and finally
point number for denying favored
treatment to advertisers donors or other
special interests and resisting internal
and external pressure to influence
covering and most of these ethical
standards are put through the shredder
by Perry White assigning Clark what
seems to be yet another seemingly random
story in the middle of Batman V Superman
benefit for the library of Metropolis
someone on the committee requested that
Clark Kent cover it probably some little
charity chrome who's got a thing for
nerds
whoa slow down your violations there
Perry you just assigned your sports
reporter to sports today to cover a
charity benefit just because someone
rich asked you to that seems like a very
direct violation of denying favored
treatment to advertisers and donors but
it's even worse in the 1978 Superman
movie where Perry White is literally
willing to give away ownership over the
company to Superman just so we can get
some exclusive coverage chief promotion
schemes though mr. white exactly how
would you know that just a first
impression well anyway was talking cheap
I'll make him a partner if I have to so
yeah The Daily Planet breaks about every
ethical rule in the book biased coverage
preferential treatment to donors
hyperbolic empty-headed clickbait titles
and willfully withholding information
pertinent to the public good but if that
wasn't bad enough here's the worst part
they've dragged down Superman with them
Clark himself isn't innocent in any of
this after all any story that Clark
writes about Batman or any superhero or
any supervillain for that matter is
unquestionably biased any direct
conflict of interest since Clark is
Superman
such undisclosed information could
radically alter the public's perception
of any story that he writes given that
he's
out there punching it up on the streets
I mean Bruce Wayne even acknowledges
this in Batman V Superman a Daily Planet
criticizing those who think they're
above the laws hypocritical considering
every time your hero saves a cat out of
a tree you ready puff-piece editorial
about him a Lee Clark makes things worse
for Lois Lane to providing her with
gifts favors fees free travel and
special treatment all of which could
radically alter her bias and stories
about not just Superman but also all of
Superman's enemies in Superman Returns
true to the title of the movie Superman
leaves and then he returns it's actually
a very accurate title but in the interim
while he's gone Lois his connection with
the Man of Steel and her frustration
with her romantic partner up and leaving
without any notice causes her to write
an article titled why the world doesn't
need Superman an article which wins her
a Pulitzer Prize you think that would
have been written had she not been all
lovey dovey with the boy in blue
certainly not you think that the pilot
surprised judges would have given her
award for journalism had they known that
she was stooping Supes definitely not
every time that Clark puts his fingers
on a keyboard he is lying to the
American people about his process about
what he knows and about what he's
thinking he weaves tails careful to
conceal his identity and his biases
leaving the people of Metropolis in the
dark and here's the kicker he knows it
that's why he's working at the Daily
Planet in the first place I gotta find a
job where I can keep my ear to the
ground where people won't look twice
and I want to go somewhere dangerous
start asking question it is done with
intention he has no plans to accurately
report the news he's using the guise of
a reporter to protect himself sorry
remind me what Superman stands for again
I'm here to fight for truth and justice
in the American Way yeah I'll give you a
two out of the three let's just leave
the truth one off the list but hey
that's just a theory Oh film theory do
you know what's wrong with Superman he's
never taken a class in journalism
maybe he would have learned better
journalistic ethics if he'd actually
bothered to study up on his chosen
profession you know what would have made
him a better reporter our partner for
today's episode Skillshare they could
have taught him everything from how to
break into journalism to how to write
the truth with style
that's right Supes that sticky bit about
truth again per agent Skillshare shirt
they support film theory so we can keep
sowing seeds of doubt into your mind
about all your favourite fictional hero
is the more importantly Skillshare
provides an entire platform that is
dedicated to teaching you about pretty
much anything still sure isn't just
about giving you information it's about
giving you thoughtful step-by-step
classes that teach you about things that
you can actually use in your everyday
life in your school at your job or at
the job that you don't even have yet but
are looking to get and all of it for
less than $10 a month like literally the
cost of popcorn at the movies you can
start any classes you want with
unlimited access over here us theorists
we actually all use Skillshare so it's
not like just a service that we're
promoting it is a service that we
actively use our graphic designer Dan is
actively watching Skillshare classes to
teach himself more skills in graphic
design our channel manager Amy is
actively watching Skillshare classes in
order to
her analytic skills in Excel literally
when one person in the office starts
talking about the classes they're taking
whoever they're talking to asks for a
subscription as well we take classes
like logo design and vector illustration
to improve the thumbnails and art that
you see on the channel when I'm going on
vacation I pull out horses like
comprehensive essential Japanese for
beginners so I can blunder my way around
a foreign country and if you would like
to join us and hop aboard the theorists
Skillshare train will then do it fast
because the first thousand people to
sign up for Skillshare using the link in
the description of this very specific
video will get their first two months
absolutely free just imagine how much
knowledge you can cram into your brain
in that amount of time you can learn how
to make homemade marshmallows and then
learn how to vlog about it with classes
in indie filmmaking and Sony Vegas
editing software so get going to the
link that you see on screen or the link
in the top of the description skl sh /
film theory - again it's linked right
down in the description so one thing you
don't have to learn is actually how to
type it into the URL bar just click it
get in there and sign up for a whole
world of free classes now if you'll
excuse me I have to follow up with my
choux pastry making class Great British
Bake Off here I come